tables will have to go when pubs and
restaurants reopen on July the 4th but
just how many depends on whether there
has to be 2 meters between them Howard
hopes it'll be less he owns 5 pubs and
is already looking at losses of 1.2
million pounds across the board then at
2 meters would lose approximately 50% of
our tables or capacity but 1 meter which
we've currently laid all the pubs out to
to see what to see what happens we lose
about 12% so whilst it's not not
desirable it's acceptable a review of
whether the 2 meter rules should be
relaxed has been commissioned by the
Prime Minister the government is going
to get advice from both scientists and
economists now they feel they've
suppress the virus they are clearly
grappling with how best to deal with the
economic nightmare it's left behind that
nightmare has been eased at the [ __ ] in
in Derbyshire by diversifying they've
been doing take away food and they've
opened a village shop that's kept Ryan
in work but he's looking forward to
welcoming more customers we're putting
restrictions in place you know no face
masks gloves everything not everything
that we can do all the sanitizer points
you know cleanliness everything will be
you know 30 so I do feel like we can we
can't do it on one meter definitely
hundred percent those using the pub's
new shop were relaxed about a potential
rule change the first thing that comes
to mind is common sense you know I think
if everybody's respecting the space and
just be sensible
I think we've somehow got to weigh up
the balance so life can carry on you
know the economy can carry on and yet we
remain safe I think a lot of people are
already beginning to sort of get closer
than two meters when you look
so probably it's probably the right time
to formally consider relaxing it less
distance means more customers and a
greater chance of businesses surviving
the economic case is obvious but will
the scientific case be as clear Lisa
Dale Sky News Derbyshire